we are getting the party started a
little early for mexican independence
day this year and we have gsa george the
beverage manager at gina poblano joining
us today welcome hi thank you for having
me i'm excited to be here you brought us
some goodies today that's my job tina
poblano at the cosmopolitan it's a
phenomenal restaurant great food it's
kind of it's like a fusion of chinese
and mexican right well we like to say
it's side by side we we have the best of
mexican cuisine and the best of chinese
cuisine side by side
we have noodles we have tacos we have a
lot of dumplings super delicious but
for mexican independence day we are
actually showcasing our margarita
vendetta flight i actually made you one
for yourself i love this now bandera
means flag
yeah the three cocktails actually
represent the colors of the mexican flag
and i'm actually i pre-poured a little
bit of the pomegranate one that i gave
you i'm just going to give it a little
shake so i've got the red part
it looks like you are shaking up which
one now
this is mine okay
what's in this so beautiful concoction
malagro tequila with a little bit of
triple sec pomegranate concentrate and
then we are going to top it off with a
little bit of salt air
did you say salt air yes that's the foam
i taste the salt air
oh my gosh
yeah there's no salt on the rim it's
literal air and this is just amazing
it's our fun way it's chef jose andres's
favorite way to drink his margaritas is
through the salt air instead of the salt
it makes it a lot more fun game changer
oh my gosh okay so you're making one
there you've got the regular margarita
yes so this is a regular saltier okay
our pomegranate flavored saltier and
then this one's our ron cooper which is
a riff of a mezcal margarita with a
little salad gusano which is a spicy
salt okay so cheers to you tell us how
people can enjoy these delicious
concoctions and when the the menu starts
so mexican independence day we are
actually doing the specials on september
16th through the 19th
guests will be able to
order the
vendetta flight as well as two
food specials so we have a chile and
nogada which is like
it's a stuffed poblano pepper with with
a pork piccata and a walnut sherry sauce
we only bring that fur of the mexican
independence day peop guests always come
to order that
it is a staple everything is amazing and
now you can enjoy the best margaritas
ever with assault air thank you guys so
much for joining us cheers we'll be
right back